uh uh
[music]
woo woo
oil on wood
eie
[music]
ah why uh uh
co
[music] uh uh uh uh uh [music] uh uh
[music]
uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh uh
[music
] uh we
222 uh 222 it's
on
uh uh uh uh r.tee [music] we dur [music] [music] we [applause] [music] erwin oo ah ah  Ah 8 Of course 4.13 I want
[Applause]
[Music]
my cover
Haha
[Music]
na hoon-a The
details are similar to what we did, not what we did
[Applause]
Yes
ah ah ah we are not anymore, both of us  Please read it
because of us, so it's because of us,
people who are flattered are great, psychological, sleepy, that's what you have to do.
Untitled is really hard. They really
wanted to give it to you. I think they all ran away
.
I'm going to change it, so I'm afraid that daylily is somehow not happy from the hat in summer I don't like rivals
Why if my nephew
q Lutz and my dad come out
[Applause]
to be a good, but
then do it domestically around the time Lee Ki-woo
My lord Pong 3 Please give me your anger
Ah Ah Man Team Bonjin and 4
Ah hey Manu has to hit this one right on the ground I'm going to split
more sisters and ride the
3rd
[Applause]
5 2 Please take a picture Now let's do it.
Okay, now it's not the scene, but now we have to go to number 5 odbc Hangul is
fun outside Let's
talk about moving things when
we ask for it.  I like to talk hard, stable, competitive under everything
It's too short. I believe in false advertisement Daom tour. It
's not true. It's not true. It's not. 28c
It's getting a side kick, but it's
going. 0 If it sprouts twice, you have to buy an expedition
team
. You have to help.
So let's pay back the language, this is not a problem
Next Next
[Applause]
If there is a director, that’s right.
Oh well, now it’s done. How did you wrap your waist? It’s not good. Finish
the touch pen data
. Here’s the car. It’s our shift. We put on fleece before
it’s very hot.
[Applause] That’s
right,
I just fell asleep half-span ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
ah ah  I have to go to the jewelry side to get a pair. Why not?
Fortunately, when I go to college, I catch a little bit of everything and continue to top it.
Moreover, the strategy doesn't work. It's not good.
It
hurts in the top 10, I fell in love based on the fact that it hurts in the top 10.
Collaboration between the two districts. Um, hey, in this temple, ah, this is also a night. It's a waste to put the defense budget on the half moon
.
I think it's going to be a good thing to keep talking about
ah ah, it's hard not
to be in a corti-up.
I showed you, I won't sing for a second  It was filmed by a super uncle,
even the qualifications, the professor, the dieter,
you easily tell me why you did it and the
records, but there is no better than that
.  I'm going to
say do
n't tell me what
to do
I'll see you at Gilliam's business this year Yes Ah, the two of us chatting again, my
sister-
in-law, you said four hours each, but no, you have to
hold on to it in earnest.
Please stab me even when commenting 4
That is, in fact, what is the case 5c Let's hear the flame Qualifications Create a flame instead of a home,
and they made a point 10 episodes Another
encounter another corn 4 0 4 5
I have to stay but I have to get a ticket  Receiving
more than writing a photo Oh I found out what could be good for me ah ah ah
ah it will come
true  More death
ah gal kindly seotda 3 Now that the field is open, looking at a certain distance while looking at the distance
ah ah visceral thing p
we hope that we will proceed, yes
it is itself c before, mulgol, both players are
like that.  Please give me some money
Oh depending on the senior car 2 Gold Tosa Cha In need to use it well Yes, this
paper is doing really well and I’m more used
to it.  That's what I mean
4 5 I'll subscribe and give you a lot of a0 yesterday, no matter how you did it
It's the same.
I really hate books and burs, so I can't take out the side or 4 5 guitar frees Wow
we don't mount Tizen Cousin L button Gudeul and Lu Daewoo in comments Now add mac and read it
like it's cool Don't do anything cool Don't
say anything inside the left old road  Why are you reviewing the stock? Why is it that you spend more and lose more and
lose the box
and get called This time it’s cheap and it’s reasonably cheap 4 I
threw it out kindly if I can’t come out of here, I’m not sure about the adoption,
yes, I still don’t know
the polyol.
Uh, let’s plant sheep’s fodder clearly, and why should someone else’s basic posture become a hero?
Oh, I don’t know
.  I won't go on a trip Josh has what
he has, so he's packed with complex numbers Yeah, George isn't weak, yes uh ah
ap y'all have to show it to harmonize with
it  I'm going to pull out the object tower. I'm going to take damage from this.
Where did I have to earn more? If it
's an bang-nim here, I'll give you a good chance
Oh, it's really hard to put this on and release it.
I see it as an opportunity. Looking at the book, I feel like I'm going.
Then let's
do it. Ah Halla. Shall we do an education? Because we can't use a single house that's going to work, individual
play is
right for a large company of mother-of-pearl beads.
]
o myeon
combined
[Music]
power